what is the one question about the hills
that you always get that you never want
to be asked again do you still talk to
Justin Bobby
nothing truth in time zone we were
dating and then a he filmed with me
first season that never aired nobody
ever saw that and then we didn't really
talk until third season and then you
know we started hanging out again
it was points whether it be romantic you
know spots where we would get romantic
and be very comfortable and then I think
life and the show and working elsewhere
other than the show kind of just pulled
us apart but uh it was we were mostly
friends for the most part it was hard
adjusting cuz towards the end with him
and Kristin and all that stuff that was
definitely kind of fake but the stuff
with us it was like it was a fine line
of real and fake cuz there we definitely
had two real feelings for each other and
what we were going through was real
mm-hmm but it's like what we were going
through in real life we didn't talk
about on can't on the show when when he
did start like fake dating Kristin how
does did that piss I mean did that piss
you off
Kristin's really good about just like
let's just do this who cares I'm down
for whatever and for me it was like
there is some real feelings involved
with Justin at a time so I kind of had
to get used to it for me it was hard
separating the two the fake from the
real so I just took everything to heart
and it was like previous is like Audrina
just do the scene just this is that
mentally think this way I'm like okay I
will but it's like but what if this
happens and I was such a worrywart what
do you think the biggest misconception
about you on the show was that I never
spoke up because that was the biggest
struggle with me and the producers you
know it's like I had stuff to say I
stuck up for myself or you didn't show
me in this light are you you just showed
me staring at them and not you know
speaking my mind so I think that was
hard for me is that I was always shown
in a light where I was just kind of
sitting there listening all the time and
not giving they would never like let me
let my voice out or so with editing it
was tough